today marks if you can believe it one
month since Hurricane Maria made
landfall in Puerto Rico
president Trump yesterday rated his
administration's response to the crisis
10 out of 10 he welcomed Puerto Rican
governor Ricardo versão to the White
House on Thursday the president gave his
blessing to lawmakers to help build a
new Power Station on the island but the
situation is still dire there for many
Puerto Ricans David beg no met some of
the most vulnerable people whose lives
may now depend on getting out of the
territory
Carmelo Diaz has lived with amyotrophic
lateral sclerosis or ALS for 29 years
the body of this former tennis player
has failed around an otherwise healthy
mind
it's a ventilator that keeps him alive
he needs it all time the power goes out
here right off and on Hurricane Maria
cut off access to power and water Diaz
who communicates through facial
movements tells his wife Betty he's
afraid of dying if he stays here I just
spoke with a foundation in New Orleans
that is ready to welcome you and has a
place for you
there was no mistaking his emotion it
was one of his relatives who found help
through team Gleason a foundation
started by former New Orleans Saints
player and current als patient Steve
Gleason are you ready to go he say no
he's torn that's a familiar feeling for
many Puerto Ricans who've decided to
leave there is no official count on how
many have evacuated since the storm but
Florida officials report more than
52,000 people have flown in from the
island this month alone Lizette Santiago
is keeping track of which neighbors are
leaving this house this house this house
her husband hey Suze gotta say Soto is
battling stage four ureteral cancer why
do you want to leave why because we
first met him two weeks ago their pleas
have been heard the American Cancer
Society has evacuated about a dozen
patients on charter planes and is now
making arrangements to do the same for
goddes a Soto it is an issue of life and
dr. Lillian Santos oversees ACS
operations in Puerto Rico the people
should have a choice and the option of
getting the best standard of care and if
the choice is said in the States we're
gonna do everything to make that happen
Carmelo Diaz was evacuated earlier this
week and put on a plane headed for New
Orleans in Puerto Rico my husband was
afraid to die be here I am very happy
one of his first visitors at a Schnur
Medical Center how are you doing Steve
Gleason the man who helped get him here
and though neither can physically speak
the power of this moment was easily
understood for CBS this morning I needed
beg No
well one complicating factor we're told
some medical facilities on the US
mainland are not accepting Medicaid
we're seriously ill patients from Puerto
Rico the concern is apparently that the
program which isn't as well funded in
Puerto Rico might not be able to
reimburse them for pricey treatments
whenever you see david stories you
realize there was still so much work to
be done there and even though mr. Diaz
couldn't speak you could really see his
emotion and he said I found a place for
you to go it's heartbreaking still you
have to realize people in need of care
need help and this is beyond just the
water and the electricity those who need
medical care and we do not yet know when
the power will be restored now